we've been looking at uniform circular
motion for quite some time and we've
established the important things right
in terms of vehicle motion because we've
we've saw with horizontal circles but so
what up bird's-eye view right now we're
looking down at this vertical motion no
forces acting okay so we don't need to
worry about that here but we have this
central force acting yeah so either in
terms of your angular velocity mi Omega
squared or as we looked at this morning
more helpfully MV squared or R and we
realize that that can be counted from by
tension and strength or gravity or this
morning a bank tracks right so if we
sort of elevate one part of a road like
sir and some angle and we're heading
along this normal force the reaction
force is pushing you toward the center
right so you stay on the road now here's
the problem but when you have a bad
track you don't have major how do you do
this we already discussed that you've
got like your friction on the wheels and
that's cool it okay but as you'll see in
a second sometimes you don't have much
friction on the wheels to count on
now I had to show you this because I
thought okay what everyone can ride a
bike I can't assume this anymore
now as the son as his cyclist is
rounding his corner you can see what's
going on and they're the cameras it's a
slight angle but you can see what's
happening in a second is a shot which
I'm going to freeze that makes it really
really obvious okay
in order to go around the turn and to be
able to do it at sufficient velocity to
you know he's trying to go pretty fast
you can see what he's doing he doesn't
have it in maintenance
instead he's baking well he's making
himself actually in terms of aircraft if
you've got a plane that's it's like this
to turn from side to side they call it
banking right so this is the scenario
that we've got and this is what we're
going to finish so let's draw ourselves
a fresh diagram let's imagine looking
onto this guy and I'm not even going to
bother trying to draw a cyclist okay but
if we have the vertical okay like this
this is a flight so let's imagine this
is a cyclist just cycling on the normal
straight path no photos okay
but he's off at an angle so he's off
something like this okay so there's my
cyclist you see now because he is
banking because he's baby right friction
is no longer acting in the same way as
it would if he was just upright okay in
fact friction is taking him this way
okay now it's a horizontal road it's a
horizontal work so this is the normal
the reaction force and this over here
it's F not the force but for friction
okay it makes sense now
what we want is for him to vague at just
the right amount at just the right angle
such that he's going to head in but he's
not going to topple how do we make sure
things don't topple I want you to think
back to when we had the keys on top of
the flat surface so when you look at
this scenario here's my
is now what makes this a stable
situation we'll get these strings out
the way what makes this a stable
situation is that friction here is
acting directly onto the body it's not
going anywhere right so if you were to
draw the friction force here well it's
not moving but it would be facing in
this direction the same direction is the
normal okay in this situation it's going
in another direction because he is
banking okay
now when you add up these two forces
together in order to make it stable you
want the sum of these two forces the
resultant force to be going just like
with the keys right exactly in line with
the object because if it's not for
instance suppose he baits so far over
that the resultant force was not this
way but you know say over this way what
would happen to the cyclists they'd fall
over right because his body is this way
forces acting this way and down he goes
okay so what we want is for this angles
to match up exactly so that the
resultant force lines up exactly with
the cyclist like so okay
so we're gonna call that R for resultant
force I know that we were trying to
avoid putting on forces that aren't
really forces that's the sum of two
forces but I'm putting here so you can
see it's got to line up with the cyclist
we might even label him as such okay now
we need a bit more information on here
in order to resolve the forces and see
what's going on okay so when you had a
bank track it made sense to say well
we'll call that angle theta that's the
most sensible place to put it
that's the UM inclination from the
horizontal okay now what do you think
would be the most sensible place to put
an egg on this diagram let me label some
things let's call this
see D so now we've got a cool woman
system which angle would you name which
angle do you think is the most
appropriate to say he's an angle that
represents how far I'd banked how far I
mean client what do you think d DB wish
DB a who reckons DBA YB do quite a few
of you okay now is that obviously you
can see I can define any angle outline I
think a BD is a good choice though it is
a good choice okay so I'm gonna put feet
here the reason why I think it's a good
choice is because what's the normal
situation the regular situation you're
cycling along and you are up right so
you would say I'm at zero degrees that's
my normal situation just like here
what's the normal situation of a rotor
answer horizontal right so here theater
is how much am i change from the
horizontal but because we're talking
about a cyclist is usually vertical
right the change is measured from the
body so far so good so let's try and
resolve the forces here and see what's
going on okay if I've got theater over
here I can join up some moment and this
theater okay so the two forces that I'm
interested in right F magnitude along
that way and management up that way okay
they're related by well if you put F oh
yeah okay because I've got um I've got
opposite sides of a rectangle here no
problems right in relation to theater
have a look at this triangle here abd
just put it out when it's funny right
you've got the friction force going in
that direction you've got your normal
force going in that direction and
there's Thea so what trig ratio would
you choose it's just an why don't you
you can say ten feet up and that's equal
to F over m okay so that's useful
because it relates it to by the angle
that we've got okay so now that you've
done that we've got the diagram we've
done treating geometry that's pretty
much all there is to it what would be
your third step
you can peek think back to the conical
pendulum we want to resolve right
horizontally vertically
okay so horizontally actually physically
first because very simply what forces
are there what forces can you see you've
just got one vertical force and right
and it should be well these on a flat
road is we don't want them to be bumping
up and down or digging into the ground
right so you've got that force exactly
equal and opposite to gravity right
so in fact we really should put that
yeah so that's what's happening
vertically okay what about horizontally
this is a little more interesting what's
the only forces acting horizontally in
this case it's a centripetal force which
in this case is just a winter friction
factors banking you're avoiding
frictions going that way so the friction
should be equal to now we're talking
about a cyclist right so is he likely to
think in terms of radians per second
probably not right so therefore we'll go
with mV square on orbit okay so can you
see how I can put one two three together
how would you do it what would be a nice
neat way of putting them together we can
do some division right what would you
divide by I've got F over in here right
I've got F here an engineer so I'm gonna
go three on two I think that's the way
that I would do it okay because that
will let me bring ten into it okay so
that gives me on the left hand side F
over m does it give you on the right
hand side V squared on our G so fast
with me so you're getting this 10 feet
up from equation one
now desisted familiar this should look
familiar
this is almost exactly the same as what
we saw with a bad track right shouldn't
surprise us because what the cyclist is
trying to do
is mimic this situation except he just
doesn't have a bet he's making it in his
body okay so what I really want is the
angle theta equals so I got tan inverse
Nagar okay so that's that's how I find
the angle of inclination away from the
vertical based on how fast I'm going
and what's the corner that I have to go
around how big is it or how small